hey guys i'm ryan right so today I'm
checking out a video that I'm really
excited to check out actually called
Owen Wilson says Wow Wow
that's my oven Wilson impression Wow
yeah I really like Owen Wilson I think
he's actually very underrated as an
actor I mean yeah he's famous yeah he's
got him a lot of big movies done but I
still think he's pretty underrated but I
want to see this really bad because I
[ __ ] love it every time he says Wow
seven projects wow wow wow wow wow
gonna be our honey I know wow
right right let's go shoo Shelley no no
look person oh wow wow wow this is a
nice boat Wow 715 Wow welcome to the 700
club kid hey I can see our hotel from
here wow it looks great
traditional American Foursquare Greg's a
male nurse wow that's great
Wow a little heart and everything Wow
a long way from home boy did it take
began wonder start steaming in wow
that's a good message I don't know what
it is about this city why are so
dominant yesterday know what to be
honest I come in it's like a little like
I'm trying to get my bears car tuned
your mama it's like you still got it
I really enjoy that I really did enjoy
that I mean there's not much to review
about it but with Owen Wilson man I
really think he deserves more
recognition you know he showed that he
can still really act when he did
inherent vice but you know we all know
him for his comedy Shanghai noon wedding
crashers Starsky know you guys know all
the [ __ ] films but he has his new
movie coming out called no escape or he
co-stars uh Pierce Brosnan I think he
looks great in that that could be a
really big turning point for him in his
dramatic career like he looked super
intense at first I was like would I
really buy him in this role but as a
trailer progressed I was like yeah
wow wow he looks like he's doing a good
job
Wow you must improvise that line a lot
or something but if there's one actor
who could pull off the word Wow it's
Owen Wilson because he's someone who
seemed so genuine so sincere all the
time that when he says wow he does seem
generally fascinated when he says Wow
anyway guys they should telling me that
was out if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter where if we get enough followers
we can get product placement like CDs I
would love to get product placement from
CD companies CDs are great you can put
music on their files you know I have one
CD that's files of everyone who sent me
nude photos that's my girlfriend know
about it no no she doesn't
but what would you say if you saw some
of these photos you'd be like wow that's
a lot more guys than I thought there
would be